I'm super excited about the the last
episode that we put out last Saturday we
put out this Biden piece oh and I know I
there's the Alex exhale but it's
something that I'm really proud of you
know the episode did really well I think
as we got over 4 million views so far on
it raising all platforms so Rogen
retweet it but there's the reason why I
was super excited about doesn't retune
it well know I'm gonna get it too I'm
gonna get to it I mean the reason why I
got the four minutes cuz Joe did that's
it but uh highlight the ones that don't
worry don't worry we'll get there I'm
we're on the same page so but the reason
why I'm so excited about is because
basically when we were looking at like
this landscape and we're looking at the
people who do shows we thought that
there was like a white space in the
market and why white space that just
means like there's a part of the market
that wasn't being satisfied right yeah
and the reality is it's my opinion the
realities most people are pretty
moderate I hate the term moderate
because it sounds like there's not
greatness attached to moderate like I
don't identify as like a moderate person
would you like it hot and I like it
moderate it's just such a stupid term
but reasonable I think is a better term
and then one issue pulls you to either
side right yeah I think it's like okay
I'm pretty reasonable about all things
but I think abortion should be illegal
so I'm gonna vote for the guy who says
abortion illegal but I'm cool with all
the other [ __ ] that you guys want
doesn't matter so when when we come
together and we want to like put
together a piece like this I'm always
like how do I feel in my gut your gut is
not is apolitical all right right how
you feel in your stomach when you see a
fat person fall and you laugh yeah
that's just your lizard brain going
that's funny it's not the Democratic
Party saying you can laugh at that or
the Republican Party saying you can't
laugh at that whatever it's just what's
in here yeah and I'll always want to do
comedy from gut right just the lizard
brain gut what's funny and we basically
came together were like we have to do
what our gut is telling us about an
issue every single week no bias no
political slant no narrative that like a
network that's tied to a political party
and is really a mouthpiece for that
parties tell
us that we can say like The Daily Show
or John Oliver one of these guys who
like they obviously have to give the
left-leaning take we don't have to give
any take we'll give whatever take and I
think what happens is when you give
whatever take when people watch it it
resonates with their gut and when it
resonates with their gut both sides of
the aisle come together and appreciate
it and with this piece you have Rogan
who's I think on the reasonable side
repost it Charlamagne who's on the
left-leaning side and at times far left
right leaning side repost it and then
later that night Donald Trump jr. repost
it and we lit his pops on fire you can't
say that we didn't have tons of jokes
about about Trump like we [ __ ] lit we
made sure we lit him on fire
in it and to me it just goes exactly to
what what I want to do when when we came
together to create the show like what we
want to do is like we want to make
something that is not politically biased
we want to make something with the
opinions not decided before we just want
to write the funniest joke we want to
have the funniest take and when you do
the funniest take truly both sides can
come together yeah and it was just
really cool to see that happen all in
the same day you have all these people
that would think they would never agree
on anything right come together and all
agree not as [ __ ] as fired it's just
funny y'all gotta watch this yeah so I
was just really proud of this that's why
I was saying how I was gonna mention
Charlamagne I was going but I am I was
and still am super proud with what we
made ivy the reason why I dislike Trump
jr. reposting it because by him
reposting it it makes it political it
makes it like oh it can appear to be
like oh hey if I'm okay with this that
means he's flaming the other side more
and that's what I dislike I love the
fact that Rogan Charlamagne anybody in
entertainment cool but if a politician
posts it now it's like he could be using
his energy to try to politicize this and
that's what I know we have no control I
mean but I would anything he does
reflects his father and I
and I would say I would say you could
say the same thing about like people in
an entertainment you know they have a
certain slant you know politically
speaking and yeah that's fun it's it's a
different coming from an entertainer
that it is coming from I understand what
you're saying I understand what you're
saying I just fundamentally disagree I'm
not gonna ostracize anybody from
appreciating comedy and for me what I
focus on is not whether he liked it or
not what I focus on is a guy like
Charlemagne it's not like solemn a
repost a lot of my stuff yeah right it's
like it's rare Charlemagne repost my
stuff but he this bit resonated with him
so much he was like yo I got to share
this with people that Rogan could feel
that Charlemagne could feel that and the
exact opposite of Charlemagne Donald
trum true could all feel that about the
same piece yeah it just shows like I am
proud that [ __ ] was dope we're the best
we've only made three episodes we're the
best at it I decided suck a dick jar of
[Laughter]
like you know you guys just stole the
John Oliver scroll thing on the side
it's like yeah yeah yes because we want
you to watch John Oliver and go Otis is
worse we want you know exactly who were
coming for but yeah it's cool three
episode ends where the best and you know
how you be the best you just don't have
a political slant when you have a
political slant as a comedian it's
perfect sample with SNL this way SNL's
trash you're telling us how you're gonna
go about the joke every single I know
where the jokes going every single bad
let me guess you're gonna make fun of
Trump the best sketches on SNL the ones
where you flip it on us
right like the black jeopardy thing that
was genius yeah cuz you don't see it
coming
you can't show your cars as a comic so
if we come at it every single week and
you don't know where we're coming from
and we literally trust our gut and
sometimes our gut is gonna lead liberal
on something maybe it's gonna lead
conservative but it's just gonna be our
gut you're gonna find people from all
sides of the aisle come together and see
it and that's what happened at our
[ __ ] comedy shows anytime we go you
see our audience is crazy diverse crazy
diverse right you see holy [ __ ]
and someone with a mag a hat in the same
laughing at the [ __ ] jokes same thing
could happen with the piece as long as
you won't decide you're gonna have a
political slant mm-hm I just thought it
was so [ __ ] cool that we did it man
no reason I think that Trump jr. repos
it all so I feel like the Trump's just
know like how politics works and there's
just like a mudslinging contest like we
were talked about before yeah in that
like even if we go after his dad he's
like all right whatever like they
understand like for them they're like
Teflon like the insults like drop it
comfy in the mud
yeah and the whole family gets it so
he's like all right yeah
daggers roasted but that's collateral
damage yeah yeah you want a mud sling
with the Trump's too like we live in the
mud let's go like we could have gone
twice as hard on Trump and he's I feel
like he still would have reposed as long
as there were some shots on Biden
because ultimately like is collateral
damage yeah he doesn't care that's what
I think yeah but the reality of about
the piece was it wasn't meant to be
political the piece was literally this
is how I feel about Biden and Mark felt
that way about Biden and Alex felt that
way about mine we didn't come together
and go how do we feel when you and I
wrote the piece and then we always read
the piece to Alex to make sure that we
were not going too crazy and Alex will
give no it's me baby I pull back here
this that the other did you find that
there was any issue with it when we gave
it to you no I mean you gave a couple
good notes I felt like but like you were
like I agree with this emotionally here
so I agree with the message I was just
worried about it being like piling on on
Biden and I was like okay if it looks
comes across that way people are not
going to take the message in they're
just going to see it as a oh we're just
disinvited yeah so it's like I've really
wanted people to get the message I'm
like try to balance it out yeah where
it's like hey we're just showing both
[ __ ] political parties that's it
piece of [ __ ]
it's nobody have no options it's we're
[ __ ] that's the point of it and it's
like everybody feels that way and if you
tap into things everybody feel parties
mean nothing their parties are just the
manipulation tactics they use it's like
I'm gonna bully you to vote this way I'm
gonna bully you to vote that way in this
hour create division create separation
[Applause]
you